das ist wirklich mehr als krass die
hawaiianische insel namens ist ein und
ist tatsächlich komplett vom ozean
verschlungen worden
und das fast über nacht das macht selbst
forschungsteams fassungslos und sie ist
bereits die zweite insel in dieser
region die komplett überschwemmt wurde
wie das passieren konnte und welche
fatalen folgen das mit sich bringt jetzt
ein klick zum science fiction hier gibt
es täglich faszinierende wissenschafts
videos abonniert den kanal denn nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
konkret geht es um die hawaiianische
insel ist island im pazifischen ozean
sie gehört zu den french fries vom
durchmesser her das größte atoll der
nordwestlichen hawaii-inseln doch anfang
oktober passierte es und ist island war
quasi über nacht verschwunden damals
wütete der hurrikan namenswahl acker im
pazifik er wird mit zu den stärksten
tropischen stürmen seit beginn der
aufzeichnung gezählt mit einer
geschwindigkeit von bis zu 260
kilometern pro stunde fegte er über die
region und auch wenn er glücklicherweise
nicht auf land traf das von menschen
bewohnt wurde sind die folgen verheerend
firmen hat hektar groß war ist island
ursprünglich und somit die zweitgrößte
insel des franchise shops der
klimaforscher charles fletcher waren
noch im juli auf der jetzt verschluckten
insel schon länger war seinem
forschungsteam klar das ist island
irgendwann einmal untergehen würde
doch die fachleute gaben der insel dafür
noch einige jahrzehnte designer ist
nicht die erste insel dem ozean
verschwunden ist auch trick island wurde
bereits vom wasser überschwemmt doch
dies dauerte mehrere jahre zudem sind
die fachleute auch äußerst überrascht
wie schnell ins island im ozean
versunken ist ihr könnt es euch
vielleicht schon denken wahrscheinlich
liegt es am klimawandel
dass die hurricanes immer heftiger und
intensiver werden darüber hat mir schon
mehrmals hier ausführlich bei pixum
science fiction berichtet in einem
interview sagt fritzsche ich hatte einen
heilige scheiße moment und sagte 'oh
mein gott die ist weg das macht sie
ziehen falls das ökosystems dieses
planeten wieder ein stückweit instabiler
und tatsächlich die insel hatte
beispielsweise für die grüne
meeresschildkröte eine wirklich
existenzielle bedeutung sie diente als
zentraler nistplatz und zwar sage und
schreibe für die hälfte der weltweiten
population
das ist wirklich tragisch vor allem wenn
man bedenkt dass die grüne
meeresschildkröte vom aussterben und
und es bestätigt auch der biologe
charles widmen
es besteht kein zweifel dass dies die
wichtigste insel zum nisten der
meeresschildkröten war und auch für die
hawaii mönchs robbe ist der untergang
der insel fatal denn alleine ein siebtel
der weltweiten population wurde auf ist
island geboren fest steht also beiden
taten fehlt durch den untergang der
insel jetzt ein zentraler lebensraum
forschungsteams können nur in einem
kleinen punkt entwarnung geben denn die
tiere waren von dem wirbelsturm wohl
nicht direkt betroffen sondern waren zu
diesem zeitpunkt bereits weitergezogen
was der untergang der insel langfristig
für die region und die arten dort
bedeutet das steht noch nicht fest
das können die experten und expertinnen
wohl erst bei der nächsten sommer
expedition untersuchen nicht
ausgeschlossen ist es auch das ihs
island irgendwann wieder auftaucht fest
steht aber dass selbst in einem solchen
fall die landschaft oberhalb des
wasserspiegels lange brauchen wird um
sich von ihrem schicksal zu erholen ja
wenn ihr kein video zu diesem und zu
allen anderen themen in zukunft
verpassen wollt dann abonniert klicks
und science fiction auch auf englisch
denn auch da gibt es immer mehr
videopremieren dafür einfach hier
draufklicken und hier drunter da geht es
weiter mit exciting discovery ice age in
europe the stream kam touristenziel
bis bald hoffentlich auf dem englischen
kanal csu
stay tuned